the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license
your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to offer high
quality educational resources for free
to make a donation or view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
all right welcome back everyone I can't
wait to hear about your projects and
trips so today you guys are going to do
presentations then we're going to go
through a really quick review of the
design process which is appropriate
because we have a really quick design
process to go through and then you guys
will do probably no brainstorming maybe
a little but then doing few charts to
figure out what projects make sense for
the class to work on the semester and
then part of that will be you're gonna
do like micro presentations at the end
of the class that you'll prep during
class so that you guys can select what
projects you're going to work on tonight
are there any questions or anything to
note while you before we get started ok
and so ideally we'll do group of Phoenix
first and then hasta pro star and then
hasta Phoenix so ok so do you guys want
to start so hi everyone for those of you
who don't know is Jaime
we're group of Phoenix we traveled to
savannah grande which is 20 minutes
south of ocotal which is one of the
bigger cities in nicaragua for spring
break and we were there for five six
days and had a lot of fun so um the
first thing i'll talk about well this is
our group ok it's like what a group I
guess we should introduce ourselves
Jessica
and this is horny he is like the shop
manager field like on-site field kind of
manager guy he's a go-to guy basically
you hear his name over 300 times in an
hour I'm being shouted hothead get us
this hard to get us that so a really
handy guy I hope we were able to give
him a deal Abha know so next time so
we're not gonna talk about this first
we're gonna talk about the charcoal burn
first um so when we got there the
itinerary was to do a lot of charcoal
burns because that was one of our
projects possible projects to work on
and there's a lot of opportunity there
because when we got there on Monday we
had our first burn with them and they
showed us the briquettes that they had
been able to make from their Friday burn
Friday burn and this is what came out of
it and as you see it remember from our
four kept making it's really great
especially when you compare it to the
blackness of this darker charcoal which
is a successful burn and successful
briquette made while we were there so
this is what we made with them this is
what they had made the Friday before we
got there and there was improvement yay
um in this picture you see all the white
smoke which is basically the water vapor
from the barrel burning and it's because
when they use the Friday this was using
the same biomass at they use Friday
which is this corn stalk and this corn
stock apparently wasn't dry enough it
seems like it was dry enough but when we
when we were burning it did we see that
it wasn't actually dry enough for the
Bukit um at the end of our presence of
our week there we were able to make over
150 briquettes um the two burns and so
we yielded 150 briquettes before they
were only making six to seven of these
briquettes for each charcoal burn and
they were you know looking at us
frantically because when we got there
they already expressed that they did
have a big interest in charcoal making
because they're starting this is a solar
sensor and on the other side of the
field is the restaurant that they're
gonna start operating and one of the
fuels that they want to use is charcoal
briquettes to cook in the restaurant so
they wanted to make this like
economically feasible and ready to sell
for the
for the people of Savannah Grande
possibly to resell it to oka tan and so
we were able to get a better yield for
them um some quick lessons learned so a
little bit of the history Amy came in
after Judy
Judy is a random service volunteer that
came to the women of total I've got to
the soul of women of total alpha and
taught them how to do the charcoal burns
but apparently she told them completely
wrong because she the timing on covering
the I'm stealing the barrel like we all
know was off and so because of that they
were only yielding like six to seven and
it was like burning too much so it's
getting a she she didn't teach them
little checks so in essence at the end
of the so what we did I'm sorry what we
did is that Kurt and I sat down with two
charcoal captains we called them two of
the women were made charcoal captains
because Kurt and i briefed them like
extensively for like a four hour period
and instructed them on like what the
instructions meant the diagrams ones
that we have in Spanish and so we went
over the translations because the
Spanish that was translated into
sometimes was a little different in
Nicaraguan so we did that translation so
they could understand that better and
then we made them in charge of as
captains they chose two other women and
that those four women were the charcoal
committee so these two women the
captains instructed the other two women
on the process so now it's a little bit
more of like an internal thing you also
learn better when you teach right and so
by the time that we got there on
Thursday we regrouped and on Thursday we
did the charcoal burn in the morning
with all four of them just leading the
way they would say every step of the
process before they did it and it showed
that they really picked up on it and by
the afternoon they did another burn
basically completely by themselves um
they're successful key points that they
really pick that really showed us that
they knew what they were talking about
was when we would ask them in the middle
of it all you know just to check how do
you know if it's good it's a good burn
and they would say oh you got a crack it
open and the heart has to be black and I
would say oh okay how do you know if the
made the biomass is too wet they would
say oh because you have a lot of white
smoke and that's bad
and I'm like so what's the yellow smoke
blended say all those are the
contaminants and I'm like contaminants
but that's what the wood has when you're
cooking with it right and they go no
it's different because and then they
would be able to explain all the process
and all the logic and really get to the
wire things cool
so we basically for our second for the
Thursday burns that just described we
went out to the fields and collected
biomass that had been sitting there for
a month so it was way drier and and so
this prompted us to think about a
possible project for us to work on at at
least something to think about which is
whether to bring the biomass into the
center and burn it there or figure out
some way of like being able to do the
burns at the fields like where all this
dry biomasses and because savannah
grande is quite a large area we thought
maybe that could be something that we
could think about particularly from the
cost perspective which liz is going to
talk about in a little bit but other
things that we're looking at as far as
possible projects are also this solar
dryer for briquettes because we
discovered in interviewing the woman
that the biggest problem they had with
the process was having to air dry these
briquettes for 3 to 4 days outside and
they didn't want to like take them
outside each day and then having have to
bring them back in and then be worried
always about the rain so they work on
these they they're their primary work is
on the solar ovens but they also do
solar dryers so we experimented a little
bit with using these and we think that
one project we could work on is a solar
dryer specifically for charcoal
briquettes so they can start making
these really quickly kind of as kind of
like almost like a factory so that they
can supply them to their restaurant
and achieve scale there and so this
shows some more of the process this is
the new biomass that we brought in that
was away dryer this was our second burn
and here this was the the Burkett making
process so one other thing that we
thought could be a potential project is
experimenting with the like cornstarch
versus yuca versus like using banana
starch because they have they come just
by corn starts there pretty cheaply and
it's much easier for them to do that
than have to like grind up this you go
for binder so those are basically the
range of projects that we're thinking
about right now as far as charcoal want
to talk a little bit about the cost
study no so we also like really quickly
did kind of cross study so that we could
kind of ensure that teaching than
charcoal was actually useful because
they basically wanted to get paid like
10 cordoba an hour which is like 50
cents an hour and work like you know
seven hour days and so based on those
numbers and like roughly how many burns
we thought they could do in like one day
if they just kind of did like a bunch of
burns in one day and just had a few
going at a time maybe we thought that
like they would be able to sell it for
like a slightly cheaper than you could
buy it a no kitaro which was like a 20
minute bus ride away so that it could
actually be like a feasible option and
they also really wanted to use this
charcoal in their restaurant so
hopefully if they really get into this
and they kind of get a lot better at it
then they'll be able to actually use
charcoal and it'll be like economically
viable as well as you know a clean
alternative also going to talk about
solar ovens which I think you ago um
this is kind of like their solar oven
that they have kind of all over the
solar center it's sort of like the
symbol of the solar woman that we were
working with because it's sort of
something that they build they like
paint in this bright color they all like
work a lot of hours in the solar center
and then like
they build up or certain like number of
hundreds of hours they can find one for
themselves just some other woman have
them at home and they can use them to
make things like cookies you see here
which they can't actually make like you
know in on a wood fire so a lot of the
one really enjoy them and while they're
not really very economically viable
option they're sort of like a way of
bringing the woman together which we
thought was really interesting
they also there was a Cornell group
they're working on these solar ovens to
try to improve their insulation and
other smaller parts while we were there
so we worked a lot with them and they
actually built a new oven with
fiberglass insulation while we were
there so we got to see how they were
built we feel is that there's not too
much more that we can add to that
project as opposed to the many other
projects that are there so really the
only projects that we think we should
possibly pursue with regards to the
solar cookers was the solar dryer for
the charcoal and then that was the final
charcoal that were supposed to be before
so right now they make their way works
is that the group grupo Phoenix gets all
of the extra small panels from the US
and they buy boxes of the panels that
don't pass says here in the US and for
about 500 of the small panels it's about
$500 the problem is that shows about $1
ourselves sorry sir so about a dollar
itself the problem is that are the 500
so that they get
about a hundred to 200 broken depending
on the box it's more than that and so
there's a really intensive project
process of making this out the Panasonic
over it okay I'll expand is later which
is this enough said okay do I just talk
I'm just like or was there another side
okay so yeah so first they connect them
all and they call them change this order
so chains they so they're everything my
hand says every single cell by hand in
and every chain by hand then they move
these changes independently so to this
paper and then after they they place
each chain independently they then add
liquid silicon all over the panels by
hand and they have to make sure that
it's evenly spread one and there's no
air bubbles and then they get the glass
and they you have to put it evenly on
top even your top and then by hand they
kind of try to push out all the air
bubbles are still in there then they add
foam and add batteries and this kerrigan
and knowing process cuz they have to put
each battery at the same on two
batteries at the same time to have even
pressure across the cells and then you
leave it there for 24 hours so the last
air bubbles can escape and so that it
can be completely flat and even so
there's obviously a lot of improvement
twenty-four hours to make one of the
largest solar solar panels and they
cruise about 220 watts so some of the
prices were thinking about a word he
mentioned instead of having to place the
batteries to have your pressure maybe
use the tip just and even where you can
just pull down and hold on the pressure
we're also thinking about having some
type of vacuum pump or vacuum chamber
that just removes all the air bubbles so
I don't have to do it by hand there's
also the probe there's also another
thing so using em they're thinking about
using fo vinyl acetate instead of the
liquid silicon to cover and insulate the
solar cells the problem with the EBA is
that it has to be heated heated and then
he has and then there's also every
bubbles even if it does here
so another pride puzzle project is a way
to heat it maybe using the solar ovens
which they say they did or maybe I'm
just maybe another way that could be up
another possible project
Oh
okay I've done so then so those are the
large solar panels which they use for
the homes and the using the part of the
restaurant and they're also using it to
power the solar center then they're
trying to make the small solar cell
phone charges reduce our last name and
they're shown are basically model to
this this is worth ten dollars in ocotal
and it's made in China the great thing
about is that actually comes with a cell
phone battery it fits most Nokia cell
phones and what you see on the right
side is a charger as well as well as a
lamp so not only can you charge your
cell phone you can use also use a
battery to power up a light so they'll
be like the ideal project
so yeah I'll be an ideal project
currently what they're working on is
just the solar the solar cells and
because I need a smaller voltage and
they don't really have much access to
capacitors and resistors they could go
back to it via they cut every cell by
hand using this using a dremel so that's
another cost and another way to cut the
cells instead of having to go by hand
will be another project and what I have
here is a little all battery cell phone
charger so you basically put your
battery here and then you move around
depending where your batteries and you
can charge your cell phone so we were
thinking of installing that to the solar
panel so you could charge any type of
battery not just Nokia ideally I mean
you see with that is also a cost because
like how you would actually like using
their current system their prices would
be a lot higher than one which is higher
yes right now yeah right now it costs
are really a biggest issue the fact that
each solar cell is about a dollar then
the silicon in the user was 600 grams of
the liquid silicon right now
I forget the number that's on my head
but it's all I think it's a lot of $100
for five gallons and just everything
adds up the labor I think is the most
intensive part they really use about 12
12 actual hours 24 hours with the drying
included the glass is relatively
expensive and then there's the aluminum
on the side there's also that the solar
the the tape that they have to do it by
hand which is not really tape is the
little aluminum strips so that could be
even be another project instead of
having maybe have a aluminum tape that
you can use tape and start having to
sort of solder on that could be another
great project and so we're gonna keep
talking oh and Malraux there are two
people I really make the solar cells
right now which is the guy on top left
which is Mauro and then there's another
model which is a glare tomorrow and big
model with the only male member of the
comparative of the solar woman of total
bedpan
so um so once we spent like a couple of
days there we kind of realized that a
lot of the center is focused
specifically towards like 20 women who
are part of the co-operative and so
again wondering if we did design a
project like based on what we learned at
the center would it only benefit those
20 people over or would it help you know
this surrounding area in general and so
this is actually the only slide that we
that we have for that part but basically
what we decided to do is me and Kwan
walked a couple of kilometers down into
another district called Santa Domingo
and it's the road we walked on and so
Santa Domingo does not have great
electricity so they're basically cut off
from like any conventional electrical
appliances and so we wanted to go there
and ask them what their involvement with
the center was if they had considered
other options for you know like solar or
wind or whatever and so we asked them a
bunch of questions so the first thing we
asked them was they'd heard of charcoal
and we interviewed 10 families and none
of them had used charcoal 3 if families
hadn't even heard of carbon which is
what yeah so they didn't know what it
was we then went on to ask them what
they did use to cook and they all said
firewood we asked them where they get
the firewood from Alton get the firewood
from like their surrounding communities
but there was actually one woman who
like walked three kilometres every day
just to get firewood which we thought
was kind of like you know unfortunate
yeah we also asked them after that if if
they do use some form of like lighting
at night and if so what all the families
we interviewed did have some kind of
lamps at night mostly they were diesel
lamps we weren't sure exactly how they
worked but they all either used diesel
or okuu
a go there which is pine wood or
electric lamps which run on batteries so
once they said that they do use
batteries we asked them what they did
use batteries for and it turned out that
they basically use batteries for like
three things lighting radios and if like
if they if they're big 9-volt batteries
then you could power like a cell phone
charger so once we asked them about that
we also asked him about like how many
cell phones they have if they did have
any per family and four out of nine of
the families we interviewed had cell
phones but the rest didn't and for the
families that did have cell phones we
asked them how they charged them because
they weren't you know near the grid so
apparently what they do is they walk to
a house which is in the which is in
Sabana grande to charge their cell
phones and are charged five to ten
cordoba for each you know like each
cycle of recharging apart from that I we
also asked them if they had cycles just
this was just like out of curiosity
because like we were wondering if pedal
power was was you know anyway if I mean
if it was viable and every family did
have at least one cycle apart from that
oh yeah so a cell phone battery charges
for five to ten cordoba and a 12-volt
battery charges for thirty could cordoba
yeah so this was I mean that was pretty
much it we just wanted to like get some
perspective on like off-grid communities
and it's pretty much this way
okay okay okay so well hon and said
we're doing off print interviews Liz and
I did some interviews at the different
homes of the women and we also had a day
where we cooked with the women just
engaged like their their usage of
charcoal whether they're using it or not
and reasons why and just to really get
like an insider's perspective so we
found out that most people aren't using
the charcoal they prefer to cook with
wood over charcoal basically because
they can gather it for free they don't
have to pay to buy the charcoal they
don't have to go to OPA tile to buy it
and they say like tortillas are a very
big part of their diet they make it they
get up early every morning go to the
Molina to grind the corn go through this
process and they make tortillas every
single day so it's a very huge part of
their diet and they found that the
charcoal doesn't burn hot enough to make
the tortillas so they prefer using wood
and also on their adobe stoves you can
cook multiple things at once which is
also why they prefer wood so this was a
good idea or a good inside look at like
why they're not using charcoal we also
saw when we were cooking with one of the
women that she kept on using Tinder's
from the wood fire from that wood fire
and she'd dumping it into the cart to
the charcoal to try to light it she was
having a really hard time doing that and
like a very small side project is just
better charcoal education and um and it
think it's gonna be really important to
make this charcoal affordable so that
they will see this as an option over
wood um another thing another thing we
surveyed the families about was like
their electric electricity usage and you
noticed that most people if they had
solar panels they they were bought using
green hours and because these families
don't they don't want to pay the extra
amount for an inverter so all their
solar panels are used for lighting in
their homes some families are looking
enough to pay for to have enough money
to pay for great electricity which they
use to charge cell phones
oh yeah charge cell phones and for some
some humans have TVs and radios other
families that are only dependent on
solar panel energy who also have cell
phones we saw go to their friends houses
to charge phones and which gave us idea
of having maybe a community charger
community solar power or yet some sort
of Center where we can invest in like
various panels that it does have that
does have an inverter to like maybe
charge these cell phones instead of them
borrowing their friends grid electricity
and stuff like that oh and these are
some of the homes we stayed in and we
had a good time saving time I learned a
lot just like like living their everyday
routines and stuff like that I think
that's about it
if anyone else has everything that
we'd like a lot of projects so high
we're gone we were working with a
superstar in Santa Ana El Salvador and
while we were there we worked on two
main projects just to show them and work
with them to demonstrate we did three
charcoal burns and we showed three
different communities how to make corn
shelters for themselves so bringing down
a project that had already been done
we're just going to run through kind of
our some of our pictures from charcoal
and explain kind of how that one so at
first didn't have a oil barrel when we
went down there so we had to go to the
co-operative in one of the communities
and find an oil barrel first of all and
then find someone to cut the holes for
us so Miguel was kind enough to drill
our holes and then we brought it to the
community and we just if we did three
different communities on three different
days and all three communities that we
went to were really eager to help they
all wanted to be a part of it
this particular got right here it was
part of a community that was looking at
charcoal more of as an economic economic
goal I guess they wanted to sell the
charcoal as opposed to using it because
they had just acquired new stoves or
they're using wood that were outside so
they're better for ventilation so these
are just some of the pictures from that
they're all really excited about the
charcoal at the first day are burned and
ghosts of all we learned that using
pretty wet sugarcane wasn't great they
hadn't dried it very well and sugarcane
to start with was a lot more dense than
some of the material we have used when
we burned here and we just didn't let it
burn long enough but it was also good
for the community to see that if they
didn't let it burn long enough then they
want to get a good charcoal from it and
another thing we realized is that when
the first day when we graded the yuca we
did it in relatively bigger pieces so it
was still pretty dry didn't like release
any of like I guess some juice or
whatever it has in it so when we
grounded up it was still really dry and
so when we added it to the water to make
the binder we had to use like so much
you got to get it to have that right
consistency so what we didn't make a
like the one you didn't make a whole lot
of binder so we learned to put it in
smaller pieces to me people were like
some people were somewhat familiar with
charcoal sometimes they had no idea but
it was really nice that everybody I mean
we I guess we kind of expected that but
everybody worked with us and they came
up with their own way
and the I guess the two tour guides not
tour guides at the background the two
people helping us from the
organization's from a suppressor were
very helpful and they got really into it
and so for the last one we actually
asked them to do the demonstration and
we were kind of checking and making sure
everything's okay so that worked out
really well in terms of involving the
community actually to keep doing this
because they're gonna keep showing
people in different communities that was
important for us to to involve them a
lot in the process they got it down
really fast so by the third day when we
let them run it we kind of it was all in
Spanish and we couldn't follow most of
it so we were to ask our translator on
Karla's so who was working with us and
one of the Qi people who was working in
the community he like we asked him oh
did you remember to tell me this like
yeah yeah so like he was just throw so
it was really good it's really exciting
to know that they'll have the like the
know-how and the confidence to really
accurately tell more communities how to
make the charcoal this is only know she
was one of the other community partners
that we worked with she was really into
like the motivational aspect of it so
she'd always be like si se puede like
you can do it like she kept like
encouraging the people in the community
that who are a little more nervous about
it or who are more depressed about their
living conditions that like they could
keep moving forward so she was really
excited about the charcoal
it was a lot of fun that pretty much
everyone in the community was really
involved with it we at least on the last
day we really kind of sat back and
didn't really do anything and let Juan
Carlos and Elena take the reins at least
with the instruction but still the
entire time the key members of the
community were really doing everything
and they jumped right in no one was
really very hesitant and there was
something a little bit first everyone to
do when we crushed up the charcoal there
were a lot of kids in the area so they
just went to town stomping on the rice
bags it was it was really a lot of fun
and the person that was drove us to the
community what was that
Julio he one day he sat there and just
made charcoal briquette after chocolate
Birkhead he's like oh look once I've
made her me so it was everyone was
really excited about it I'm someone look
with the corn sellers Amy Smith have
gone down in some of the communities had
seen or had heard about using cans that
they had to make the corn shellers so we
had never heard of that but we were kind
of trying to go with it and the first
day that we went out we had to
experiment we using pliers and the camps
that they had so this was one of the
communities that they were just playing
around with it and it was almost kind of
good in a way that we didn't really know
how to do it ourselves like perfectly
because it kind of allowed them to
experiment themselves with it and they
kind of found the best ways that they
wanted to make it and they're using like
little six ounce jalapeno cans so these
are some of the woman playing around
with
and then we also did show them how to
use the jig with the sheet metal and the
hammer one of the things that we ran
into though was one of the communities
didn't have pliers so we had to show
them how to do the whole thing with a
hammer and eventually by the third day a
meet came up with this idea of having
like a variable corn sheller so we
didn't actually close it and we rounded
the edges so it was just like you can
hold it in your hand and adjust it to
the size of the corn because the corn
varied a lot from different communities
so that was really helpful and this girl
was really into it it was nice when we
found the way to do it with the without
fully attaching the ends so that since a
lot of the corn were different sizes you
would see a lot of the members of the
community used one corn shell and try to
shell it and it didn't work because it
wasn't the right size so they'd like
toss it on and try another one and you
could see it was kind of like
frustrating late who wants he wants the
corn sheller it doesn't actually work so
once we figure it out kind of do it with
just rounding the edges so you could
just the how tightly you gripped it one
what made it work for every single corn
cob it was a lot more exciting when we
first showed it to them that day the
lady tried in like promptly like put it
in her pocket and went around with it
with the rest of the day it was really
it was amusing
the third community we went to actually
we went in like toured houses and looked
at stoves in between like when we had
first shown them how to make them and we
came back like a few hours later and
they were still like all sitting there
making that like they had been doing it
for hours on end they loved it
now we're going to talk to you about
some potential projects we came up with
so there I guess as an introduction
because our trip was and we just went
with it we really didn't know the exact
projects they were working on so we took
a lot of notes and there's so many
different issues that they're dealing
with and a lot of them are not energy
related per se but we took notes on all
of them and well I guess we can pass
that on to other D lab classes but we
picked four as like the main projects
that we can focus on in the class and I
guess the main ideas were lighting
optimization ventilation a charcoal
insert and a rice husking modifying a
meal to do rice husking and
okay um so one of the big problems in El
Salvador is there's only 3% forest right
now they're running into a lot of issues
with people using all the wood for
cooking so although some of the families
wanted to use the charcoal to sell it
and make money off of it other families
we're looking at it as a fuel source for
themselves for cooking but one of the
problems with that is that they were a
so pro so our team was working with the
communities to build new stoves outside
and those stoves weren't optimal for
charcoal this is a picture of one of
them see if you can see it has like the
nice chimney so it ventilates really
well and it's outside and so it burns
really well with wood so we were
thinking along the lines of something
that we could insert into one of these
types of stoves that would make it be
able to use charcoal we a lot of the
materials that they have there we
thought we thought like up about sheet
metal and we thought about different
ways to like kind of make a kind of
fryer basket thing but Hsieh metal is
too expensive for their living means so
we for our project we were thinking
about something with the cans that we
had talked about they used for corn
cellars they can buy them in the market
and there they have food in them when
they come with them so that they can use
the food and then we can we were
thinking about potentially making the
cans and just like forming it and
weaving it into some kind of charcoal
basket that we could insert into these
stoves so they could cook with the
charcoal that they make
it's something important I guess to add
for all of these was that
I think all three communities and I
think one was a little bit better but
than the other ones but they really
didn't have any resources like we spoke
to a lot of a lot of the people and it
seemed like most mostly women most of
them are not working so it was really
difficult to ask questions like can you
afford buying something because most of
the time they don't really have any any
money so it's I guess that the biggest
challenge is try to find materials that
already exist or maybe are part of the
trash and we we spoke to people trying
to figure out what are the type of
things that they can find and the I
guess the cans is one of the things also
the chips bags and tea chips bags was
mentioned as something that it could be
found near schools
plastic bottles any size of plastic
bottles can you use so things like that
we were trying to see if we can somehow
incorporate any of this into into the
design so that it's not really something
that you can go by because they can't
really go by it
so the second problem that we identified
as something we could address was rusty
husky so they were some of the
communities were starting to experiment
with integrating rights into their diet
as well as their standard corn and beans
for additional nutrients or at least
having it as another source of to sell
potentially but currently the problem
was if they they could either shell all
the rice by hand or they could take it
to a mill that was about three hours
away and they had to pay about 250 to
get the bag the husk and then they had
to come back so was it like very long
and tedious process they spelt well over
there like a couple days salary or work
just doing this and its really not very
economical and it's very hard so they
experimented with a mill to grind that
they used to use to grind corn to the
husk the rice and they to make it softer
they had some of the communities had put
rubber in between the pieces of the mill
and but they found that the rubber was
turning the rice kernels black and which
is not good so we bought a couple mills
and experimented with other materials
which included a lighter color rubber
material and leather so it's more
organic material to place in between it
and we tried that Saturday before we
left and we had a decent amount of
success with it there has to be some
more fine-tuning obviously and probably
more to potentially find some more
optimal materials to use as the barrier
but from what we found it's definitely
got potential and it shouldn't be too
hard of a project attack and that's
something I think that's also supported
by a superstar they're supplying these
mills to to some communities
so that they can use it
almost as a microcon
the insert kind of goes like right in
between two pieces that they are both
like
I guess fridge so they cried to gotten
to each other but when you have
something in between that kind of stops
it from pulling the rights totally apart
for the lighting there there were a
couple of different issues one was
electrical lighting and Wednesday
lighting for electrical lighting some
some communities
some people had lights inside some had
likes that worked and some that didn't
work so it was very the conditions vary
whoever the families we asked about is
the the light bulb enough a couple of
families said yeah for four at night
they they had one room you know
it was sufficient to light that room in
terms of day Lighting's so the houses
were completely very dark very dark and
one of the I guess some of the questions
we asked is are why why are they so dark
and is that more it's expensive or do
you need more light and so most of them
were one or two rooms and they had one
window the whole house is one of the
rooms sometimes didn't even have a
window and we found out that there are a
couple of different issues one was money
because the houses were made with adobe
bricks in order to leave I mean it seems
simple that you just leave an opening so
that you actually save on material
however we've been for a safety and also
for hurricanes they have to close that
opening and to close that opening if
they use wood or metal it costs anywhere
around twenty-five dollars per window
whereas the bricks or thirty cents so
that's three dollars versus twenty-five
dollars
it's a big difference another issue they
said was some of them didn't actually
want more light because of privacy
reasons parents and kids sometimes are
in the same room so they were saying
they were kind of joking around but they
said you know we can't do anything
because if you can see things kids are
always aware of what the parents are
doing it
so it was more of a privacy issue
however daylighting could be improved or
it would be great if they have more
light for all the tasks they're working
on and some of the ideas we had were
again using existing materials and there
so we saw this at we met a Peace Corps
person from Texas who used this in his
house and he said that the roof was
leaking so he just put a plastic bottle
instead of one of the roof tiles and
that was actually without a really great
idea because plastic bottles are
available and if we can find a way to
maybe cut the bottle in half and try to
mimic the shape of the roof tiles and
incorporate some plastic bottles within
the roof so that stops the rain but
allows like to come in
that was one idea another possibility
was there was a gap between the wall in
the roof from about six inches in most
homes and even though that's a lot more
challenging we were trying to think of
is there anything that we can introduce
some sort of a surface that can catch
some of the light from the outside and
bring it inside something like the chips
bags which is kind of like aluminum
to redirect it however that's
challenging because the roof or the
ceilings or and walls weren't completely
black from the smoke of the cooking
inside
which I guess leads to the last so I
guess so last project we were really
working on was the ventilation so like
you only said like a lot of the homes
still had the stoves inside and a lot of
them were simply the three brick stoves
they just stuck the wood under it and
proceeded to cook and it essentially
charred the walls completely black and
it was a lot it was covered in soot and
with the financial problem of trying to
even incorporate windows into the
housing which so much more expensive
that we really had a difficult time
trying to think of ways to improve the
ventilation especially considering the
fact that a lot of the members of the
community on it don't make money they
just live off the land that they have so
the idea of buying materials is pretty
much impossible so one of the thoughts
we had other than improving the stove so
that they're more efficient trying to
get them to move outside which they have
problems with since the stoves they have
right now are not very efficient they
have to make sure they close off the
entire area for wind and rain because
they're already losing efficiency just
with the stoves that are using so a lot
of them wouldn't mind like if they don't
leave the stove inside they built like
an entire new room with the roof and a
wall outside of the house to put there
this is a start-up one of the like
outside kitchens that they're making so
they like literally closed a section off
with walls and then they're going to
probably put something over for a roof
so essentially if I'm making an entire
new tyranny or
and that's and that's supported by a
suppressor what they're doing is trying
to find families for it I have the most
need in a way and they're supplying them
with
sometimes materials they said that the
way the organization works is they never
actually do it for you they would get a
grant from somewhere and actually make
the community do it but these stoves
that they're building outside our
kitchens aren't not for everybody in a
way so there are only certain families
who get them so it's still a really big
issue of how do we deal with the stoves
inside so we thought as far as a
makeshift smoke could essentially since
there was the gap in between the house
the house and the roof we thought that
maybe we could make some sort of hood
out of the materials that they already
have maybe like overuse clothes or a Sun
even like the chip bags there or some
way to like sew them together and
channel the smoke at least up into the
cracks of the house and hopefully guide
it a little bit more outside of the room
that they have because essentially they
are just one room Hut's more or less so
there with no windows and one doorway so
there really isn't anywhere for the
smoke to go if it's not if it can't be
better channel now and since it is only
one room you sleep there you eat there
you cook there so it's the ventilation
is pretty bad and one of the things
so I'm adding on a more positive note
though it was an amazing experience like
we said all the communities were very
encouraged and you really wanted to make
these changes there wasn't anyone who
was just kind of the what was me too
depressed even try to make the change so
it was nice to know that they were
really really into me making these
improvements it's sometimes something
just add something importance as a
Procera the way they work with these
communities is to help them but to also
help them and so there was a really big
influence on how can we make some of
these improvements but not hurt the
remaining nature that we have
so a lot of the other issues that we
encounter or water latrines how do they
make them without actually contaminating
so I guess part of these challenges is
to figure out ways that
for nature any more so than what is
already existing because
the biggest issues there
okay so introduction wise we were the
group that went with also Phoenix also
Phoenix is a group that's based out of
Managua it works with a group called
green empowerment but it's based out of
Portland so it's really quite a good
guerrilla collaboration but anyway they
focus on bringing kind of potable water
systems green energy solutions to
different towns but the really cool
thing is when they go to implement these
things they bring a lot of
infrastructure with them because you
know oh we're going to install a water
system well you're going to need an
energy source for your pump well you're
gonna need a road to get all your
equipment there well you know everyone
should have a clean latrine so it
doesn't clean the you know dirty the
water system so they really do a lot of
compound work and that's why it was
really exciting to travel around with
some of their insurance see what they do
firsthand so I guess we'll just run down
we went down there with four projects in
mind and we are going to present those
four projects and where we see further
action like possibilities for each of
those projects are so we'll start with
the juice sealer the bag sealer which
was a project from last year's class
which seals the plastic bag for the so
that they can preserve juice the woman
are working on in the community so we
went down and this machine device runs
off of power from a 12 volt battery and
we went down and since last year they
have installed and like connected a
micro hydro plant to about half the
houses in the community so this house
that we were staying in actually had
like 120 volts of like power coming out
of like a normal outlet in the wall
they did not have any more batteries
that were not dead
so we tried multiple ways to get that to
work clarification is coming out of the
wall was AC and the device had a
solenoid that did not like AC at all
there's only really didn't 120 volt yeah
they did I do so I tried reflecting with
like a corrugated metal piece of roofing
onto a solar panel but didn't have
enough like current coming out of that
to run the device and then we also tried
charging a battery a car battery or that
they had from before the micro hydro
plant but that battery was completely
dead I get charged from like 1.5 volts
like one point nine volts in three hours
so then we strung up those batteries
that you saw in the last picture here to
get to work so we could at least give a
demonstration and that was some good
compo engineering
and so we were able to give a
presentation and they were pretty
excited about like being able to seal
the bags but leaving them a string of
batteries on a stick taped together is
not something so we for this project we
can further develop it by making it so
that it can run off of the AC power that
they have and then we also found out
after they left at some houses that
aren't on the hydro electric grid still
have solar panels and charged 12-volt
batteries so bettering the design for
this project to suit that because they
might depend on what we hear back from
also Phoenix they might have to take out
the air in the bag so the seal would
have to be a seal for the juice airtight
and no air in the bag to completely
preserve the juice so that they can sell
it after the peak orange harvesting
season then there's a market for orange
juice
so yeah moving on to go sorry these
aren't in water
sure so another cool project that we've
got to go and see was a bio digester is
yes this is the same one that we went
and saw in a town called fort Doritos
it's hooked up to the grid right yes the
power has come to puerto rico's but they
you know people still cook on wood
stoves and a great way to supplement
that is with methane from bio digesters
like this one so this one belonged to a
household where the woman cooked twice a
day on it but it would often run out she
had really no idea how much gas it was
producing so one of the projects we went
down there with was to make some sort of
simple yet elegant meter for her to tell
just how much gas was in it a pressure
meter essentially yes okay so our simple
combo engineering solution was to take a
piece of clear tubing we had brought
Markov some increment so you can see
whether or not the gas coming in from
the tank which is the great piece of
conduit there would press against the
water so basically you would read where
the water in the tube met the air and it
would indicate if the pressure had risen
or Falls there yeah so it's also a
pressure release system which is really
important if the you know bag gets to
over you don't want the bag to get to
overfilled with gas and the pressure to
get too high so basically with the
pressure somehow got to the end of that
six and a half inches of tube which is
highly unlikely since you uses it every
day the gas would simply just bubble up
to the top however there were some
difficulties that we noticed like was
with the daily feeding this machine or
this system just in basic use of it we
hopefully solve that one with
this kind of simple meter but another
one was just it's a very messy task
basically it's a whole five-gallon
bucket of manure that has to be mixed at
a one-part manure three part water
mixture and then added and it poured
through if we go back to the picture of
the entire system they could look poured
through a relatively narrow pipe and
it's just very sloppy and messy it's
also entails mixing the you know manure
and water in a bucket she had like a
little trowel that she did it with us
and I got nice and dirty giving it a try
as well and yeah it's just a messy
procedure if we could come up with some
sort of device that would mix the mix of
slurry in the bucket as well as kind of
aid and pouring it not only would it
make this a lot easier to use and you
know be able to make her help her get
her tours done much faster but it would
kind of make bio digesters less messy in
general and I think that's or we
imagined that would be an applicable at
a market for by jesters in the States by
a testers in other developing countries
it would be a very young trans mutable
project
okay so one of the things we went down
we did a lot of thinking about before we
went down was washing machine doing a
washing machine so we had some extra
time and burritos as we were waiting for
the biodigester to see if our levels of
gas was changing so we talked to several
of the women and got them to show us how
they're washing clothes in this case
they're doing it in love and Dara's big
concrete wash basin thing but by our
house but most of the woman weren't
actually washing them down by the river
yeah under stones and you can't see if
there was a well outside of that picture
me asked them a lot about so so watching
him the close by hands involved a lot of
vigorous scrubbing and also used a lot
of water in this case we were using
about that entire two gallon bucket to
wash one shirt she said that she used I
believe it was like about 30 gallons of
water a day from doing the washing and
she did it every day and this was only a
preacher's only dude in the Washington
three and three people because most of
her kids were grown up and not around
anymore so imagine that a lot a lot of
families that are larger would use even
more water so we started asking about
what they think about the task of
washing and whether they would like to
use a machine or not it turns out that
there's actually very mixed feelings
about the tests of the Washington
clothes some some women really don't
like it some enjoy it more than other
tasks it would rather did that some
get bored and say that it's something to
do and so they enjoy it for that reason
and if we ask them they would use
bicycle-powered machine in general they
were Punch we think they didn't really
understand the concept of powering a
machine off a bicycle it was a very
hilly area we didn't see a lot of
bicycles especially off the main roads
that were paved and
might have been better if we have had
pictures of that to show them the idea
across but in general the response was
that they didn't know and if it worked
and it worked if it worked if they liked
it they would use it but they couldn't
say now some specific things about
potatoes is that they have a water
potable water system and they pay money
for it so there was a machine up by the
house hell did the Russians still by the
river so if there was a machine up by
the house houses that they would have to
use it would have to use almost no water
because they don't want to pay for the
bar the well that was by the river is
which we first we thought might be a
good place to put a machine was actually
built by a few families and they own it
and other people are supposed to use it
and they own Blandon that it's theirs
that would cause issues about who could
use the machine who it was for we
considered a portable thing that would
be brought down to the river but there's
already a lot to carry down and it would
have to be very lightweight and not
bulky and then in general there isn't
things that the women aren't doing
because they're washing clothes it's not
really taking time that they would be
spending like making money or anything
and especially with the finances in most
households controlled by the men there
isn't much motivation for them to spend
money on a machine to make the task of
washing clothes easier so if in Porter
at us we found that there were a lot of
obstacles and we didn't think that it
could really be implemented implemented
successfully there we moved on to all
the Cote which was where we originally
imagined the project and there was a
better situation they had one place by
the river that everyone washed for the
dry season
and there would always there were
already a couple laughs and Dara's
they're the people with the women would
use and there's often multiple women
there but again it's only the dry season
that's everyone everyone spreads out the
one river during the wet season they're
getting water pumped to their houses
soon so people are unsure about whether
they're going to be washing up by their
houses especially if they have to pay
money for it or down by the river
there's a main path that goes right by
the place where they wash their clothes
and animal lots of animals come by there
to drink and stuff so it would need to
be very secure against the theft of the
animals we also heard that sometimes the
women will fight over the best spots to
wash their clothes which we would be
afraid that it was like a machine that
made it easier might exacerbate that
unless it worked so quickly that no one
minded the way tea time and then we had
the same concerns about like from the
the possibility motivation for fronting
money for a machine water conservation
was talked about in both these cases but
we were there in the dry season and it
didn't really seem that they were
concerned about actually running out of
water so we're not sure that that would
be a good motivation either so even
though we did a lot of thinking about
this beforehand and the situation would
be slightly better in La Cote we don't
think that it's really an appropriate
project to work on especially compared
to other
other projects we saw it seems to be
more of like a solution in search of a
problem than then something that needed
to be solved and if somebody really
wanted to work on a washing machine the
best way to do it would be to it could
be maybe done be done as like a
demonstration thing that AUSA Phoenix
would have to give people a better idea
of what we're talking about when we say
washing machines and bicycle-powered and
stuff but it would need to work really
well in order to convince them that it
was something worth switching to so over
always feel that a lot of the other
projects are far more worthwhile and
this probably isn't something so our
last project was a military which this
is Millett here on the head and this is
the raw grain after the processing so in
the town of El Cajon a coat day they
most of the families grow billet and the
processing of this plant takes a long
time it takes like the toll so to
harvest like the fields it takes between
four six days of like one man working so
normally I have two men do it takes
between two and three days to do that
then they wait 8 to 15 days for the
heads to dry for the stalks to dry and
then they cut the heads off of the
stalks which takes another two to four
and days and then the long time
consuming part is knocking the little
pieces of grain off of the head
the of the stock and the way they do
this is they have this device or
platform here where they stand on that
plank and then take the stick and hit
the heads and then the grain falls out
because that's just pieces like
individual sticks going across the
bottom of the platform so the grain just
fall through on the tarp normally they
have a bigger tarp at the bottom of this
but they just save one bag and their
harvest had ended before we got there so
but I'm a the director of AUSA Phoenix
requested that they save a bag to show
us so this is just one bag that we
normally have a bigger tarp and then
there's a guy below who's sweeping and
that's because parts of the head stock
not the grain but the head stock also
fall down and he's sweeping those black
bits out of the pile of pure grain and
then so normally in their process they'd
have two men on the plank one man
sweeping and then another man loading
more raw material up on top so it's a
four-man process and it takes anywhere
like
like four in ten days for each family to
process their harvest to pay on their
size that field depend on the yield for
that year so it's a lot of time because
that's four men working for four to ten
days so that's like upwards of 40 man
out the command is to complete this task
so - and they're the men don't like
doing this work so there's like very
easy if the machine works they will use
it so and it's as simple as that
then when you hit the heads of dust is
like emitted and that distinction skin
makes it really itchy it's also not very
good to breathe and the man sweeping
below is just engulfed in this dust like
during the entire process and they don't
at least said they don't necessarily
switch jobs that often so it could be a
balloon man just sweeping so the what
they do with this millet they cook with
it they feed the head the leftover heads
and the mixed grain that the guys
sweeping out that has bits of black
heads - livestock where they can also
separate it because they grant in water
the grains sink and the parts of the
stock stay floating so let's see for
like this project if would be great to
have a machine that gets like 80% of the
seeds because this hitting process
doesn't get 100 doesn't even get close
to 100% of the seeds out of this ahead
so if you were to get 80% of the seeds
that would be acceptable before machine
is especially given that their
efficiency right now and then also if
you had a way to control the dust from
expanding off of the machine you could
keep it
sequestered that would also be increased
the health of the Machine and
so that's that's it
so it's literally just sticks all the
way around like you can see the wall is
better from here but the bottom is the
same and the reason we thought the
reason that it's so high is so that that
you can have a man down there sweeping
and if any is not like hunched over so
and I don't know as it falls it falls
down to the the dust that's with it they
don't really want that to get in with
the rest of the grade so when it's
falling down the wind will blow it away
so that gets more time for that to
happen to a problem
okay
there were two in the community that
both of these notes that we went to we
lure self one and there's only they have
about ten also Phoenix that they I guess
installed already and they're gonna kind
of continue since dawn more only two of
those ten are operating right now like
you successfully run twenty and that was
including the one that we were working
with in the ten which we're not really
sure how much she's feeding it and how
much she's actually using it so I don't
know it's hard to say like a big thing
we're not sure whether it's because of
the mixing process that it just is
unappealing to like what is the logname
that's like creating like this gap
between like getting the gas using it or
not so if it's that mixing and we can
like take the human element like human
handling out of that process I thought
would use it every day then that would
make a big difference but if there's
another problem like we'd have to
address it more
you